I think one of the hardest thing that
we've got the new yorker to sustain and
to keep bettering is humor I am I think
I once took Roger Angell out to lunch
Roger as a writer who's been at the
magazine for a very very long time as in
his 80s I said you know Roger I've been
doing this now for a couple of years and
it's easier for me to get somebody to go
sleep on the ground in Sudan and dodge
bullets in Afghanistan that it is to get
something authentically funny and he
nodded and he said well that's very
interesting because you are now the
fifth editor of The New Yorker to tell
me this beginning with Howard Ross and
it's true it's true not that being a
foreign correspondent or dealing with
dangerous as any small thing but humor
at the highest level whether it's saul
steinberg or SJ Perelman or david
sedaris or whatever is a very very rare
rare thing now as far as cartoons are
concerned you deal with the cartoons
that come in and then select among those
and I work very closely with Bob Bank
off the cartoon editor in doing that a
difficult thing there is getting young
cartoonists we have any number of
cartoonists who are of middle-aged late
middle age and older but it's tough to
make a living as a cartoonist I think a
lot of the people that might think of
becoming a cartoonist do other things
which are a hell of a lot more
remunerative we have some cartoonists
who are in Hollywood like bruce eric
kaplan somebody like roz chast is able
to do what she does and do more with it
in the art world and in the human world
but it's a tough go it's a tough go
you